demo Bank is a fictitious banking
institution with a rather ordinary
mobile application a year ago they
decided to embark on a modernization
journey and get more innovative with the
micro services based architecture the
purpose of this was to allow the
developers to rapidly deliver new
features to the market the first such
new feature was a virtual assistant
which uses public cloud services
including artificial intelligence
weather and traffic to help their
clients with directions to the closest
no fee ATM or updates to branch hours
based on weather events the application
update was a huge market success and
demo Bank was able to gain market share
they were able to extend their
application architecture to multi cloud
while maintaining their compliance
thanks to the IBM cloud pack for multi
cloud management let's dig a little bit
more into how they did that and how they
came to that decision demo Bank has been
an industry leader for a long time but
has recently seen consistent declines in
market share while a new competitor any
bank has attracted a lot of demo banks
existing and future customers a strong
package of online services including
banking anywhere and mobile banking
features has driven the competitors
success an ami demo Bank CIO is under
the gun to deliver competing services
that will help gain and retain customers
ami has outlined a new suite of online
features for the development team to
build in order to compete including a
virtual assistant mobile check deposit
and face ID recognition for login demo
Bank CIO knows that developing and
deploying these new features using cloud
native architecture is the best way to
compete and continue to innovate by
boosting cross application reuse of
services the first step is for demo bank
to modernize some of its existing
application components and move them to
a public cloud and while this migration
is taking place they must continue to
keep back-end data such as account
numbers and other sensitive data on
premise in their data center and ensure
that they can manage the whole
environment efficiently and securely
innovation is the key to winning and
building cloud native while running
workloads in a hybrid environment
offers the speed to market demo Bank
needs to stay competitive but
modernization of course comes with risk
especially in the financial industry
policy enforcement is critical with so
much sensitive data and security
breaches are always a threat demo Bank
must ensure its new IT environment is
completely secure and in full compliance
with both its industry regulations and
its enterprise policies if any of this
is compromised it could mean millions of
dollars lost and a tarnished brand image
security governance and compliance will
be extremely important over the course
of demo banks development project and
will continue to be so once the
applications are deployed to production
let's take a look at the perspective of
ami the CIO as the decision was made to
go forward with this project in the
pitch meeting demo banks chief
information security officer says hold
on remember when failed Bank tried to do
something in public cloud and exposed
sensitive data they almost went out of
business from the fines and loss of
customers demo Bank CEO responded that
this is true but we can't afford to
remain idle we need to find a way that
we can both embrace new technology and
new routes to market while staying on
top of compliance and risk as the CIO
ami has to think about what it means to
her IT operations team and her sre teams
the operations manager or sres
need security and governments within
their private and public clouds the
project is under way it's up to demo
banks SRE team to ensure that the
enterprise's policies are enforced and
compliance requirements are being met
across all cloud and on-premise or PSA's
the developers deliver the first release
and it is deployed to production at
first glance everything looks green and
everything looks good in the environment
when they dig a little bit deeper they
notice a glaring security problem that
could affect the integrity of their
compliance the kubernetes network
security policy on the public cloud
services is not set the same as it is on
premise in their production environment
at this point there's no automated
function to predict or to remediate that
problem demo Bank now has a gap in its
compliance status
and customer data may be at risk without
a proactive way to monitor their
multi-cloud environment
demo bank can't effectively know the
health of the environment nor have a way
to remediate any incidents that could
arise as they move applications across
clouds when demo Bank adopted the IBM
cloud pack for multi cloud management
they leveraged security policies to
enforce the network security settings
for their production environments even
when a developer changed the setting to
a non-compliant setting the policy
engine automatically fixed it and
notified central IT once they adopted
the cloud pack as a single control plane
for their multi cloud applications the
whole C suite for demo Bank could now
sleep better at night development teams
could develop more securely Operations
teams could manage more securely all
while keeping up with the breakneck pace
of innovation in this scenario you've
seen how the fictitious bank demo Bank
was able to drive innovation while
maintaining security by using the IBM
cloud pack for multi cloud management as
their control plane for multi cloud
resources
for watching this video to learn more
check out the next video in the series
where you can learn how the IBM cloud
back for multi cloud management can help
you with all of your multi cloud
governance risk and security needs